hello to everyone watching and listening
I recently wrote and recorded a
conservative Manifesto
and released that on YouTube these are
two appendices to that document which
provides some additional information on
poverty and inequality and on
responsibility and meaning and so all
leap right into them with your
forbearance and interest
appendix one on poverty and inequality
and their nature and amelioration
it is of crucial importance that
conservatives understand and discuss
the true nature of material privation
and the unequal distribution of both
resources and Rewards
absolute poverty per se is not primarily
the consequence of individual sin or the
corruption of social systems it is
instead a brute and irreducible fact of
nature all living things are fated to
exert costly effort and Garner
Expendable resources to survive
thus the poverty that must be overcome
so that privation pain and death can be
kept at Bay and reproduction insured is
not most fundamentally or properly
attributed to the exploitation of one
individual by another or the corruption
and oppression of social institutions
the overcoming of dire want in the first
place
is to be regarded instead as unlikely
and as the direct result of laudable
personal Endeavor and functional and
sustainable social Enterprise all the
same is true of relative poverty
the equally brute fact of
disproportionate gain and loss is
neither attributable in the most
fundamental sense
to the inadequacies of individual aim or
the insufficiency of communal
Institution
it is instead something deeply and
mysteriously built into the structure of
natural reality itself both natural and
social
it characterizes
the distribution of matter within
galaxies a small number of stars have
most of the mass the movement of water
within ecosystems
a small number of rivers carry most of
the world's water the habitation of
people within geographical regions
a small number of cities have the
majority of people
the severity of natural disasters a
small number of earthquakes destroy the
most buildings
and the distribution of Natural
Resources a small number of oil fields
have most of the deposits the same
principle applies
to Performance
and the receipt of attendant rewards
within social domains
a small number of classical composers
wrote all the music of the common
classical repertoire
scientific endeavors
a small fraction of scientists published
the majority of scientific papers a
small number of scientific papers accrue
the majority of citations and Book Sales
a small number of authors dominate the
best seller charts this inequality
exists equally on the production side
in that a small number of people in
every Enterprise undertake the vast bulk
of the valuable work and on the
compensation side
in that a small number of people Garner
most of the income and wealth
a diverse range of natural processes and
every known productive and creative
Endeavor produces an inequality
that must therefore
be both recognized and managed
neither the fact of such facts which are
a small fraction of the full domain of
such facts nor the active reference to
such facts
constitutes any justification for the
existence of relative poverty any more
than the fact that absolute privation is
justified by the a priori reality of its
existence
they are recognized and cited instead
to ensure
that the reality of inequality and the
difficulty of its amelioration is both
recognized
and taken with sufficient seriousness
rather than say attributed unthinkingly
and so dangerously to say the mere fact
of capitalism or the inadequacy of
democracy or free markets
it is also true and needs to be said
that the willingness and ability to
exploit however motivated and the
degeneration and Corruption of social
systems from the family through the
state and church can of course interfere
with or even destroy the necessary trust
and attitudes and practices that
underlie a sustainable productive
generous citizenry
and Community but
and it Bears repeating that in no wise
means that such desire Decay and
interference is the root cause of the
most fundamental economic problems that
beset ourselves and our institutions
individual ambition and action rightly
manifest
and social institution properly
established and maintained
instead produce and distribute
abundantly and generously
and are compromised in those functions
by greed resentment nihilistic
faithlessness and confusion and the
political economic sociological and
Theological consequences of those
pathologies of motivation
the fact of a priori deprivation
and the operation of deep laws of
unequal production distribution and
compensation means that individuals and
societies alike
must structure themselves
so that productive people have the
freedom to be productive and are
optimally incentivized to continue
producing
however it is incumbent upon
conservatives
to appreciate in the deepest sense
possible
the catastrophe of absolute need and the
danger and potential tragedy and social
danger of radical inequality to
sympathize with the plight of those
afflicted by such realities and to note
the danger posed to community order by
unchecked disparity of ownership and
opportunity
those
who abide
by the Western Canon must therefore
support and work for the existence of a
plethora of productive Enterprises so
that many people can strive hopefully
for success in many different directions
and as well must also strive to Foster
promote and maintain an ethic and
culture of productive generosity
this best ensures a place for everyone
regardless of the vagaries of innate
ability
as well
as the proper taking of responsibility
for and atonement in the face of
absolute and relative poverty
we
are all fated
to both arbitrary and unequal degrees of
deprivation and privilege some are born
poor dim and unhealthy others rich in
both resource and opportunity as well as
ability and health
the proper response to such apparent
Injustice of placement is in the first
place forbearance and gratitude
manifested courageously and in the
second
cultivation of the desire and ability
to employ those unequally distributed
talents and gifts
in the service of the poor downtrodden
marginalized
and infirm
such service satisfies the demands of
both conscience and State
in the truest and most long lasting
senses
such service also serves
as the most valid and reliable source of
the meaning that most truly sustains us
all protecting us from despair
individually and collectively as we find
ourselves exposed to the dramatic and
challenging vicissitudes of fate
it is truly better to give
than to receive
and conservatives would do well to
balance their demands for Liberty
autonomy and tradition
with the pledge
to be caring generous and charitable
appendix 2 on personal responsibility
and the practicalities of meaning
in the absence of deep sustaining
meaning
the tragedy and betrayal that inevitably
accompany life undermines motivation
engendering a suffering that can be
unbearable
and tempting us all toward Hedonism
cynicism hopelessness bitterness envy
and ultimately
the Delights of vengeful cruelty
that meaning has become questionable not
least in the aftermath of the
philosophical and Theological confusion
manifesting itself as the death of God
young and old alike have become ignorant
of their heritage
skeptical of the benefits of adulthood
unsupported in their agency
accused
of prejudice and unseemly ambition and
fed a continual diet of apocalyptic Doom
and historical guilt
they have become inconsequence
Dangerously demoralized
despite the wealth and security of the
present day and the vast Horizons of
opportunity now available to everyone
this most unsettling of conditions and
genders and increasing distrust
as the worth of human endeavor becomes
questionable
and the motivations of others the target
of increasing suspicion this manifests
itself as a dangerous and accelerating
polarization
as shared aims disintegrate and claims
of corruption exploitation and
victimization multiply
conservatives can offer not only a
philosophical and Theological
alternative to the deterioration of
Faith producing such distrust and
suspicion but a practical guide
to The Ordering of life
such that its suffering might remain
tolerable and its stability and
adventure sufficient
the values of maturity responsibility
Duty tradition commitment
industriousness and Civic engagement are
now criticized and rejected deemed
anachronistic even pilloried regarded as
problem not solution treated as
unvirtuous and exploitative they are in
fact the opposite
the daily Virtues Of attitude and habit
that stabilize provide hope and unify
that offer a true and time-tested and
immediately implementable antidote to
the anomy of moral relativism cultural
dissolution philosophical ignorance and
personal confusion
maturity sacrifice and resistance to
temptation
[Music]
the ability to delay gratification is
the Hallmark of maturity and a crucial
part of the process of adapting to the
reality of the future as present actions
have future consequences
and to the complexities that emerge from
the necessity of adjusting short-term
individual needs to the demands of
sophisticated social reciprocity
this means that we must each undertake
to Bear difficult burdens in the present
to ensure the survival of our future
selves and equally and similarly our
families and communities now and later
that maturity
can well be recognized and promoted by
conservatives
as the appropriate and admirable goal of
childhood and Adolescent development
as a state of being preferable to those
early stages of development as a
respectable valid and worthwhile
ambition for development and as a
precondition for the establishment of
complex productive social institutions
marriage
the idea that sexual intimacy is best
contained within the confines of a
stable relationship that a man and a
woman should come together as a
permanent unit and the children require
a minimum of two opposite sex parents
for optimal development is a notion as
close to universally human as any so far
discovered distributed and established
marriage provides each individual with
the opportunity for True intimacy
physical and spiritual the possibility
of genuine elevating communication and
psychological development a solid
platform from which to engage in the
challenge of raising children
and
the profound satisfaction of engaging in
a difficult worthwhile mature Enterprise
a culture firmly based on the principle
of stable monogamy
is less prone to hyper-competitive
youthful male aggression often
manifested as a consequence of jealousy
loneliness and existential frustration
provides women with the stability
necessary to DARE pregnancy and the
vulnerability associated with the care
of young children and offers to boys and
girls appropriate role models for the
development of a stable identity and
pattern for adulthood conservatives
should be forthright
in their admiration for and promotion of
this most fundamental of social
Arrangements
all other options however desirable in
principle however associated with some
hypothetical Utopia as doomed at minimum
to comparative and perhaps unforeseeable
dire failure
this does not mean that alternative
Arrangements whether formulated by
necessity or desire should be carelessly
opportunistically or cruelly devalued
it does mean even given that caveat that
the gold standard of permanent
traditional monogamous relationships
should be broadly socially recognized
and rewarded
[Music]
a man or
loyal caring parents reliable true and
honest brothers and sisters and children
bonded in love in mutual regard is an
individual valued celebrated supported
remembered
and respected
we all therefore need to be encouraged
to work with Good Will and honest
courage to Value mend and maintain our
relationships with our sons and
daughters fathers and mothers and
brothers and sisters to stabilize and
strengthen our families and to make of
them veritable pillars of the broader
community
conservatives can and should discuss and
publicly and explicitly support the
attitudes and actions necessary to
Foster such familial integration and
should strive to do so in the absence of
a compromising doubt or guilt
the actions necessary to unify families
and make them strong in the face of
adversity are fundamentally Akin
to those that also make for Reliable
productive social institutions at levels
of social organization that surround and
subsume the intimate and personal
proper and caring practice at the local
level
thus property prepares us all for proper
and caring practice among our friends
neighbors colleagues
and fellow citizens there is nothing in
any of that
to justify a corrosive doubt or
undermining guilt
friendship
every individual is well served and well
supported by a network of friends United
in good faith aiming at the mutual good
capable of providing reassurance in
times of tragedy and betrayal able and
willing to honestly celebrate in times
of success and Triumph
such friendships
can neither be established or sustained
in consequence of dominance force and
compulsion
but by the spirit of reciprocity and
voluntary play the Hallmark of the most
productive stable and desirable forms of
Human Social organization people
surrounded by friends who genuinely want
the best for them but who stand by them
equally during times of uncertainty
confusion cynicism and despair
are in a much more stable position
existentially psychologically and
practically
are much less likely to drown in chaos
and much more likely to maintain and
flourish in an optimal order
societies composed of individuals
ensconced within such friendships
are more likely to be stable productive
charitable
and generous
employment
work job or career
is socially valued productive activity
most typically a sacrifice of present
impulse to the broader community
and the future it is necessary to say it
again not because one class or sex or
race dominates another
but because privation is the basic
condition of life and effort must be
expanded to address it work is often
viewed cynically as a curse or as an
indication of exploitation and
victimhood and can indeed make itself
manifest in the form of degrading
unsustainable and hopeless toil
under optimal conditions however both
psychological and social work is a
blessing not simply because absolute
poverty can be ameliorated through
effort but because genuine and
sustaining meaning can be found in a
task well and Faithfully undertaken
even at the most basic level of
participation in an Enterprise or
endeavor
work properly undertaken
can offer the opportunity for genuine
social contribution
the possibility of establishing lasting
friendships and working relationships
the opportunity for Learning and growth
personal and practical
the provision of rewards attendant upon
participation in a worthwhile valuable
Enterprise
and The Experience necessary for
informed and skillful movement forward
into broader more complex sophisticated
productive and generous endeavor
conservatives can make a case for work
can Nest that case within their efforts
to uphold justify and promote free
markets can Endeavor to make the rules
governing work just and fair and
arranged so that commitment effort and
Merit are rewarded appropriately
sustainably and justly
Civic engagement
the stability of state and country is in
the final analysis
dependent on the Integrity of the
individual and the family
the local Civic level functions as a
necessary intermediary participation in
small-scale local institutions which is
often where real valuable and necessary
fortification and change occurs is
therefore another necessary precondition
for psychological Health social unity
and
productive piece
sports teams book and drama clubs
charitable foundations business
organizations political parties and
churches synagogues and mosques all
offer social value and the sense of
genuine contribution that interpersonal
communion and mature and voluntary
service to others inevitably provides
conservatives can remind the alienated
and lost that the many serious problems
that need to be solved and the many
enjoyable games that could conceivably
be played
provide a horizon of opportunity
dependent only on pure willingness to
engage
conservatives could invite the
disaffected young and old alike to make
their services available
so that the community could benefit and
those offering welcomed recognized
and valued
accomplishment
ambition
in the highest and truest sense
is the motivation to move forward in the
face of difficulty disappointment
frustration privation tragedy betrayal
and malevolence and to engage in life
courageously honestly productively and
generously
this is the wish and the willingness
to develop genuine competence not the
striving for narcissistic
self-gratification and not the
expression of the will to dominate
exploit and oppress
the desire for accomplishment is in its
deepest manifestation
the motivation to first see and then
Traverse the path that provides the best
for all at all levels of ability and
opportunity it is the instinct to engage
in and value such accomplishment that is
part of our most admirable moral sense
ambition itself seen in this light
is nothing less
than the entirely admirable desire to
reduce unnecessary pain and suffering to
promote a sustainable happiness and to
create the wealth and prosperity that
makes for security opportunity
and further Adventure
it is better to give than to receive for
these reasons as well as those
previously delineated
and the purest and most admirable form
of accomplishment
is more for all
in a manner simultaneously just
sustainable
and generous
every person does not have to
participate in every social institution
or social action but it is a rare person
indeed who can live without a
degenerating misery and cynicism in the
absence of all activities and social
bonds
this does not mean that creative
exception even rejection when required
of certain otherwise self-evidently
necessary social norms is either
unnecessary or without value
it does mean however
that the creative production that does
not merely and heedlessly decimate and
Destroy must be undertaken within a
broader framework of shared assumption
perception and action
of shared Bedrock value
the conservatives Desiring to uphold and
promote the Canon of Western values can
therefore offer to all those who are
hopeless and lost even if they are truly
exceptional
the purpose adventure and support
to be found in striving forward in all
these varied domains of traditional
endeavor
that practical orientation and
accomplishment
constitutes the most reliable bulwark
against the oft otherwise demoralizing
tragedies betrayals disappointments and
Grievous losses
that characterize human all to human
conception and existence
that practical orientation
provision of Hope
and stabilization
serves
as the genuine antidote
to the Despair and bitterness that can
undermine all hope
engender accrual and vindictive
resentment
and dangerously destabilize and threaten
Society itself
thank you all for watching and listening
I've just read the appendices to a
conservative Manifesto A document I read
on YouTube and wrote over a period of a
few months
I hope that you find the information
that it contains and presents
helpful and
hopeful
thank you very much